we got this from the AP
Trump indicted for efforts to overturn
2020 election and block transfer of
power
Donald Trump was indebted on felony
charges Tuesday for working to overturn
the results of the 2020 election in the
run-up to the violent Riot by his
supporters at the U.S Capitol with the
doj moving to hold him accountable for
an unprecedented effort to block the
peaceful trance of Presidential Power
the four count indictment the third
criminal case against Trump provided
deeper insight into a dark chapter in
American history that has already been
the subject of exhaustive federal
investigations and captivating public
hearings Chronicles a month-long
campaign of lies about the election
results and says that even when those
falsehoods culminated in a chaotic
Insurrection at the Capitol Trump sought
to exploit that Violence by by trying to
further delay the counting of votes that
sealed his defeat they go on and then
add some opinion nonsense we can I think
we have the the actual indictment right
here
count one conspiracy to defraud the U.S
count two conspiracy to obstruct an
official proceeding count three
obstruction of and attempt to obstruct
an official proceeding and conspiracy
against rights
they go on to lay out their case but
there's a few interesting points I'll
pull this one up from Brett L toldman
who says I've now read the indictment
twice it is criminalizing speech thought
legal uh legal positions right or wrong
and disinformation it is also shockingly
manipulative of statuses and theories
which acquire enormous legal wrangling
further further it ignores advice of
council defenses ends and men's rare
requirements but the most glaring thing
is what's not in the indictment the
charges of treasonous addition or any
other serious fact-based count outlining
genuinely criminal Behavior the
unindicted co-conspiracists are lawyers
representing the accused a doj employee
and a political consultant and their
conspiracy believing there was election
fraud talking about election fraud and
pursuing legal challenges and States
they believed election of fraud occurred
to put it simply ladies and gentlemen
Trump has been indicted for taking the
advice of lawyers that's it
so I I think the reality is that they're
going to make up whatever reason they
can to go after Donald Trump to prevent
him from running in 2024 they'll likely
use this or whatever comes out of this
because this is going to be a DC jury
the likely that Trump gets a fair trial
is nil there's likely going to be a
bunch of Democrats who are going to vote
to indict and when he does they will
move to remove him from the ballots in
2024 for citing the 14th Amendment or
Insurrection or something that effect
yep and I I think that it's not as much
as the you're only going to see the
effect on Trump right now going forward
for the rest of essentially American
history or until there's some kind of
significant change at the in the
bureaucracy in Washington any Outsider
candidate is going to be treated like
Trump now granted Trump gives
plenty of ammo to the left to uh and I
think that's that's plenty is an
understanding yeah I think it's an
understatement but
um the fact remains they are
Prosecuting them or indicting him for
things that he was found not guilty of
with the impeachment in the Senate so he
was tried for a lot of the same things
here in the Senate when he was impeached
and they was found not guilty
it's it's it's the same stuff so they're
they're just like it's it's clear that
they're trying to make him uh either
prevent them from being the uh the
nominee or make it making you know I
think we can't vote for him you know I
think they want him to be the nominee
and then once he is they remove him from
the ballot and now they're unopposed
just cause mass chaos yep well it seems
like they're gonna they're going down
this route regardless like there's not
going to be any end to indictments if
this isn't the indictment that takes
them out there'll be a new indictment in
a month I mean we've seen it over and
over and over again they're never gonna
give this guy a break and it's
interesting to me that they tried to tie
in like January 6 just a little bit to
this even though I mean it's been proven
time and time again there was no
incitement from him you know he
basically had no role in this I mean the
capital was our the capital grounds were
already breached while he was still
speaking and then he released the video
on Twitter Twitter took it down they
took the other video down and they
banned him so how are his father was
supposed to see him saying you know stay
peaceful we love the Capitol Police we
support the Capitol Police you can't but
they're just never going to stop this it
seems like it I either my original
thoughts was that we're gonna run them
through the ringer find them guilty of
something and then take his name off the
ballot maybe that will happen the other
thing I'm just reading about it people
are like yo he's getting bankrupted and
that may not literally bankrupted but
this is costing him a lot of money I
think it's been I think he spent like
what four I saw something like 40
million dollars and he's being attacked
for it this is what I I never liked
about these duplicitous political
attacks Steve Bannon and that other dude
they're doing that build the wall
campaign they get a bunch of donations
they indict and charge one of the guys
behind it because he said he wouldn't
take a salary and then he did not a
single person who donated a legitimate
fan cared that someone got paid a salary
when they said they weren't going to get
paid they're probably like sure whatever
and this is the same thing here you've
got you've got people saying Donald
Trump is swindling his supporters by
taking the donations to pay his legal
fees
and I'm just like dude not a single
Trump supporter cares what Trump does
with them they know what this money is
going towards like they see the
indictments over and over again and even
if they didn't they're so loyal to Trump
I don't think they're going to care at
all agreed if Trump came out and said
look we took a bunch of the Buddy and we
bought a golden toilet for my plane
everybody his fans would laugh they love
it yeah especially show us pictures like
it feels good when I sit on it they'd be
like yes
yes it's warm yeah let me read this from
the indictment check this out this is
interesting section three it says page
two the defendant had a right like every
American to speak publicly about the
election and to even claim falsely that
there had been outcome determinative
fraud during the election that he had
won he was also entitled to formally
challenged the results of the election
through lawful and appropriate means
such as by seeking recounts or audits of
the popular vote in states or filing
lawsuit challenging ballots and
procedures indeed in many cases the
defendant did pursue these methods of
contesting election results his efforts
to change the outcome in any state
through recounts audits or legal
challenges were uniformly unsuccessful
shortly after election day the defendant
also pursued unlawful means of
discounting legitimate votes and
subverting the election results in doing
so the defendant perpetrated three
criminal conspiracies now this is this
is the interesting thing
they just the first one the first
paragraph they're saying or I say I'm
sorry paragraph three that he's allowed
to say these things how to claim these
things he's allowed to seek these
challenges but he also did Eagle illegal
things itself it's not that it's that
they immediately then say but he did
illegal things therefore like okay you
should list those illegal things like if
he's allowed to make these claims if
he's allowed to file these lawsuits if
all that's fine what did he do
well it seems like he's being prosecuted
for trying to legally question the
election that's what it really yeah
here's what they say a conspiracy to
defraud the U.S using dishonesty fraud
and deceit to impair obstruct and defeat
the lawful federal government function
by which the results of the presidential
election are collected quite literally
saying Trump's allowed to be wrong but
he's not allowed to be wrong he's not
allowed to lie he's allowed to be wrong
but he's not allowed to lie and say it
if he knows that it's not true every
fiber of Donald Trump's being believes
that he won the presidency yeah like
every single bit of Donald Trump you
know what's interesting this indictment
comes out too and then he got the
DeSantis Camp releasing something trying
to say like counteract the fact that you
know he actually believed it they're
saying that he knew beforehand that it
wasn't actually stolen so and then it's
interesting that this indictment comes
out and the way that it's worded so it
seems like there might almost be like
working off of each other it's but the
Santa's Camp is clearly trying to take
Trump down and I don't think Trump had
like hard evidence that it was true so
if he made the claim you can't know it
it's true if you don't have evidence the
hard evidence so it would just be an
assumption you can still believe in it
that's not a lie he was just asserting
he was just saying this is the way that
it is I know I'm confident in it the the
idea I mean it's reasonable to say that
there was some amount of error in fraud
so so Trump's just like look I know that
there were people that were suppressing
votes and people trying to blah blah but
I know that my voters came out for me so
go find those votes because they're out
there it wasn't like he was like oh
ghost stuff ballots into a box not that
I not that he wouldn't put wouldn't do
that if he could get away with it
because he would but I don't think that
he was I don't think that he had any
kind of plan to stuff ballots or
whatever at one point didn't he make
like an offhanded comment about like
voting twice or something I remember
when the left freaked out about it it
was a joke but I think uh I think
Roseanne may have been right
military tribunals by the end of the
year oh not that one rosenzo is not
going to be an election and Michael
malice said of course there will be and
then you know my response is of course
like Define we need to clarify what you
mean and I tweeted this earlier perhaps
she's right not in the literal sense
that all of a sudden there's no election
but if Donald Trump is removed from the
ballot in a single state can you really
call it a true election and that I think
is an interesting point
everyone knows the Front Runners Donald
Trump he's going to be the Nomine he's
gonna be the nominee for the GOP Joe
Biden likely unless something changes it
could change but right now it's looking
like Biden versus Trump that's what the
polls are showing a lot can change from
now and then
if there is an election and Trump is
forcefully removed from the election
it's an election because the people
aren't given the choice they actually
want I agree you can you will people
will call it an election but if it isn't
actually an election and you doesn't
matter what you call it banana republics
they call them elections but you're like
you can't you can't legally cause
America you can't legally call American
cheese cheese that's why the package
says American pasteurized processed
cheese product we call it cheese we ask
for extra cheese when we put on our
Burgers but it is legally distinct from
cheese so that's the technicality I'm
referring to it is legally distinct from
Jesus
I like the comparison what I really love
is I'm a big fan of home run and pizza
you guys ever have home running I don't
think uh Chicago famous Chicago Pizza
brand they're amazing it's really good
pizza it's like a flat pizza and um you
get these little personal ones and it
says cheese pizza with pepperoni why
because they don't have the legal amount
of pepperoni on them to be called
pepperoni that's funny right so here's
where there's there's a legal amount
I think federally but here's my point my
point is this federal government at work
the left the Liberals will remove Trump
and then say we had a free and fair
election and the right will say our guy
was removed from the ballot how is that
a fair election and the left will just
say it let me let me read you this part
of this this is crazy check it out the
co-conspirators one an attorney who was
willing to spread lies they say false
claims too an attorney who devies an
attempt to implement a strategy three an
attorney whose undefined claims of
election fraud defendant privately
acknowledged others sounded crazy four a
doj official five an attorney so there's
what is this four attorneys advising
Donald Trump and they're like that makes
it a conspiracy so then you've got we're
doing the jobs co-conspirator sex a
political consultant who helped
Implement a plan to submit fraudulent
slights of presidential electors what
they're doing is they're saying it's
false because the media said so and the
electors are fraudulent because they
weren't elected despite the fact
Democrats had done this in 1960 they
sent a slate of elect actors they
convened and did everything despite the
fact the state was awarded to the
Republicans they did it anyway and then
when it came down to the actual
electoral vote Nixon the VP at the time
counted the Democrat votes instead so
when Donald Trump did exactly the same
thing now it's fraud this is a clear
sham an attempt this is the this is the
real conspiracy this is the real fraud
happening right in front of us Donald
Trump believed stupid things don't get
me wrong Donald Trump sought to legally
remedy these things when he's on the
phone with these people he genuinely
believes that lawyers telling him these
things are happening and he's like okay
and as Phil pointed out there is not an
ounce there is not a tiny there's not a
single cell in Trump's body that
believes he did not win every part of
him believes he won how could he lose
he's the biggest he's the best he's got
golden toilets and his lawyers told him
he did so he said pursue it they're
going after him claiming it yeah you met
like not only is the guy like really
really strongly uh prone to think that
he won because of his ego then he's got
lawyers that are like yeah dude you're
totally right he's like he's
he's not going to be no everyone else is
right I I'm me and me and the guys that
are literally telling me exactly what I
want to hear we we're probably well and
it's like their jobs too and yeah
they're listed as co-conspirators for
doing their jobs being attorneys it's
just the craziest thing they're
indicting his attorneys for legally
advising him yeah I would imagine that
if the attorneys believed what they were
saying then they're not committing
crimes well in attorneys I don't think
have to believe what they're saying I
mean it's their job to defend their
client yeah that's the entire point of
it I don't even think you legally have
to believe you know you're claiming
murder cases you know a lot of I mean
this is obviously different but
attorneys represent murderers all the
time look at O.J Simpson you know he did
it but you know
there are times where you'll have a
murder case where it's like you're
getting charged with one like murder one
and the the attorney will just swear up
and down that it was just manslaughter
right like they knew that that you
killed him but it wasn't intended and
you know so details like that matter and
they'll they going to say whatever they
need to say to get their client off you
know yeah so if it turns out that Trump
believed what he was saying I mean first
of all how in the hell can you prove
that in court you can't you cannot it
only he that's why they didn't go after
perjury because it's impossible most
cases to prove someone was lying so if
it turns out he wasn't lying he was just
wrong then does that not just clear all
these other people then because there
was no conspiracy because there was no
credit you would think it would clear
this entire indictment because the
entire indictment is a you know based on
him allegedly knowing beforehand and
then lying about it so this indictment I
mean it's just BS that's the best well
so here's my question
How can there be an election in 2024
with this already coming down
because what we see here is I'll say it
again in 1960 Republicans win Hawaii
Democrats convene electors anyway fill
out the requisite forms and send them to
DC even though they lost
in the end Nixon decides to count the
Democrat electoral votes anyway because
there's a court hearing they were not
certified he says we're going to count
these ones as anybody object okay there
they go to Kennedy instead Trump's team
does that they're claiming that's a
conspiracy the deal the doj Biden
Biden's doj is claiming that Trump knew
he was lying that his attorneys were
conspiring with him to willfully lie and
defraud the country to steal an election
with them saying this and of course not
a single Trump supporter believes this
is true How can there be an election in
2024 let's say that
Donald Trump doesn't get criminal he
doesn't get convicted he's on the ballot
we make it to November and then they say
go cast your votes
how could anyone on the left believe it
if Trump wins how could anyone on the
right believe it if Biden wins yeah
that's where I have that too man like
with with people voting on a proprietary
voting machine behind the scenes and
then them just spitting you out and them
telling us what our votes said without
verification how I am lost I'm like I
I'm so far out of the political realm I
see no no solution within that broken
within that I guess you would call
obfuscated system I I can't I can't I
don't know what what strings to pull on
because I don't know where what they're
connected to because I can't see the
code what happens what happens in 2024
the day after the election and they say
the winner of the 2024 race is insert
Canada
for this country yeah how are you going
to prove it that you know that candidate
didn't win or did win you can't because
like Eaton said who's counting our votes
we're not but but I'm not even talking
about that it doesn't matter who wins
what happens to this country when one or
the other wins that's gonna fall apart
regardless I think I mean we saw the
reaction to when Trump won you see the
2020 riots you see everything that
happened and then you see the reaction
to when Biden wins you know either side
is going to be very uncomfortable
regardless of who wins it's just a
matter of you know which side is going
to be more uncomfortable and obviously
the left is always going to be the more
uncomfortable side when the opposing
candidate wins but I think they're right
it's kind of scary because in this
situation it's like they're trying to
push the right into the extremism box
that they've already labeled them in
that's their goal I feel like here they
want these you know right-wing
terrorists and right-wing extremists to
go out and act like antifa I mean look
at what they did with j6 right that that
is their goal I think here because
because then they can say look you know
these people are insane they're
everything we've been telling you they
are for the past 10 years
and it's just another I feel like it's
just going to be another step towards
the ultimate dehumanization process that
we're seeing in the country yeah when if
for instance Biden wins in 24 and then
people are just out of their minds
frustrated with the system whether Trump
got elected was in the election or not
they're going to look for like moral
Solace of some sort to not go crazy and
it's really our job or the job of you
listening you like all of us to keep
people saying keep your friends and
neighbors sane because if they do snap
they'll be used as an example just like
your sand Taylor and just what you
Hitler did when the reichstag burned
down he blamed the Communists and he
sent the whole country to martial law so
do not step on that landmine
if Trump wins the left will say oh no
the fascists are taking over he's a
criminal and he's been indicted and we
all know it he's trying to defraud this
country there's no way this is
legitimate Vladimir Putin's probably
helping him
then what if Joe Biden wins then the
right is going to say
it's clearly the Deep State it's clearly
fraud
what happens I can't I can't predict I
have no idea well did you see uh the
other day this I don't remember you know
who it was It was obviously a left-wing
he's a fairly famous character he was on
Joe Rogan's podcast and Rogan was
pushing him uh you know on the question
of you know are the bidens corrupt like
they're supposed oh yeah Jim Gaffigan
yeah and uh you know he just it was
clearly he didn't believe in anything
that he was saying he was just
stuttering and mumbling he was trying to
understand
but I think I think it just shows you
that like it doesn't matter what really
happens the left is gonna be unhappy
regardless and they're just going to
continue to get more unhappy these
aren't happy people and they can never
really achieve happiness or Solitude in
their political candidates I mean
they're unhappy with Biden still so I
think you're just going to keep seeing
both sides being pushed and pushed and
pushed and pushed until there's finally
a Breaking Point again like 2020 was I
think 2024 is going to be a Breaking
Point oh I think it is going to be too
that's what Roseanne was saying she was
saying something the fact there won't be
an election and the idea that there is
is no election is absurd but it will be
an election as people will go vote there
will be ballots but will anyone believe
the results it's a full election yeah no
I mean like it might be a I might be
real might be legitimate but no one will
be able to know that's the problem we
don't see the code tallying the votes
for us how can we know but that doesn't
even matter because it's not all digital
some is paper or some some of some of
these places do take paper ballots the
point is it doesn't matter if if the
vote is two people and you and I walk in
the room and I hold up a sign saying
Trump and you'll be sign saying Trump
and we go there it is Trump won the left
won't care they'll say it doesn't matter
that he won fascists have taken over and
now you must resist yeah I think you're
right about that whoever seizes the
power at the top it doesn't really
matter to the crowd to the to the people
to the culture and that's why I'm so
heavily focused on creating songs and
and movies right now I don't it doesn't
seem like it's a direct line to
Salvation like make a hit movie but I
mean it can't hurt it can only do good
and I know that during World War II
artists thrived you know in deep dark
times is when people really really need
someone to make them laugh or to make
them smile or to give them hope so maybe
maybe that'll well you see that all
throughout history is that's when
artists Thrive is the darkest times
throughout history and not just that but
musicians people that give somebody hope
even if it's you know through a dark
message they're always going to thrive
because people are always looking for
something to latch onto because in a
society what are you going to latch on
to now what child drag shows like what
moral things are in America right now
and as it declines even more for you to
latch onto and to be proud of there's
pretty much nothing yeah we need
structural reorganization in the United
States big time man I don't know if the
three branches of government's enough if
we need a fourth branch of government
like the national initiative microvel
was working on the national initiative
before he passed away that's an
interesting concept that microville is a
communist I don't think so that he was
lit his it's the young guys he let take
over people running his Twitter account
have kind of trash drag it through the
mud no offense guys I don't know if you
actually have but I have not been it's
not Mike Revel let's put it that way
Communists I'm comfortable with the
offense
um so if we need if we need a fourth
branch of government so that people have
more of a voice in writing and creating
laws and passing them into the Senate
because right now it's like a monopoly
of like 300 400 people they get to get
to do that but can you I don't know I
was gonna say can you really trust the
government to give people more power
because whenever you know they've
they've tried to give people more power
it ends up with them we are the
government laws inherently do not
Empower people but like every law that
the government passes or that gets
passed takes power away from the
individual and from the people so you
would be able to repeal laws also give
the national initiative I'm not sure if
that's written in but let's do it give
people the opportunity but also who's in
charge of repealing the laws and stating
new laws that's where you run into the
problem in the roadblock because not
everybody's going to agree with him and
why would the government want why would
the government allow a new Branch the
existing government the the probably the
Congress or and the the executive why
would the government allow a new Branch
to repeal laws when Congress is fully
empowered to do that now it would be
still the Senate and laws don't matter
at all anyway yeah fair enough
enforcement is what matters so either we
you know if we want there to truly be
changes in this country it has to be
cultural meaning the people genuinely
agree that something is Over The Line
and other things are not and that's
where a lot of the cultural culture War
stuff is is taking place in areas where
the right and the left fundamentally
disagree on what is okay and what isn't
okay like for instance many liberals are
okay with books like genderqueer and
this book is gay which contains sexually
graphic images they're okay with those
books being given to minor children for
whatever reason and then people on the
right are not okay with that the law is
clear you can't allow this but police
will not enforce it period yeah that's a
cultural issue I've only ever seen the
police like referring to child drag
shows which is clear I mean sexually
manipulate I mean you're taking
advantage of these kids in an
intentional way in corrupting their
minds and you know I've covered over
probably 50 of these just in Texas alone
there's only been one single one where
anything was enforced and it wasn't
against the drag performers it was
against antifa so they're not unwilling
to enforce it even though it's clearly
stated that it's against the law and
then we have sb12 passed which in
September is going to go in the state
that it actually is against the law the
revoke business licenses they'll be jail
time amongst other things but it's still
going to happen and none of it's going
to be enforced we need to show people
like when I pick up that book
genderqueer and I turn to the page where
the the young kid has like a strap on
and the other kids like getting down to
go go down on this other you're like if
I sh maybe someone needs to see me
showing a 14 year old that to see how
horrific it is
exactly but it's how can that they can't
just put it behind a curtain and say
it's fine like you cannot let that
happen
sorry Taylor yeah I mean but the left
does allow it yeah you have to go to
jail it's because they're communist
they're protected I think it's because a
lot of people don't know what's
happening so then they're just going
along with it like was on the culture
where she's like oh yeah that book's
great didn't even know what she was
talking about she didn't know had never
obviously never read the book but but
that's that that matters to a certain
degree but the real issue is
there's a there's a video of a guy
backing away from antifa in Seattle
they're threatening him with weapons and
the cops pull up jump out and arrest the
victim if you tried saying everyone look
at this book look what they're doing to
kids they'll be like oh well you just
committed a crime in courtrooms they're
like don't it's too graphic don't show
us we can't know and you're like dude
you gotta know man don't if the teacher
nothing will happen
if you are an opponent of the Communists
and you show it you will be arrested
well look it's a perfect example with
with this topic I mean you look at the
2020 riots right and then the one time
the right decides to write look at the
prosecution difference I mean when the
dissenters do something that they're not
supposed to you know while the other
side's completely allowed to it's just
as illegal they they're paid antifa
millions of dollars when they ride and D
write it in DC during Trump's
inauguration they smashed buildings that
cost millions of dollars in damage they
caused they destroyed private vehicles
that fires in the streets torched a
limousine and then when the police
arrested him the cops got in trouble and
the city paid out millions of dollars to
antifa as the victims and then a couple
years later the vice president was
hockey or plugging their uh defense fund
well you look at the Portland uh defense
fund with Rose City antifa and those
groups when I went to jail with them in
2020 I mean I was talking to him they
have millions of dollars in that defense
fund when I last talked to him it was
like 3.8 million dollars and all that
money is recycled because they're not
getting prosecuted they show up to their
trial they don't get prosecuted that
money goes right back in and they just
keeps stacking and stacking and stacking
but you don't see anything like that on
the right who has control of that fund I
don't know somebody somebody has control
so how do we get blue how do we fix this
stuff man how do we get in there and
make this like us I think it all comes
down to culture I think that's the most
understated and you know I mean I would
say underestimated aspect and Tim has
done really I mean this whole crew has
done really good on hitting on the
culture more so than anybody on the
right is we should be making movies like
daily wire we should be making songs
like Tim you have to affect the culture
to change it I mean you got to change
people's minds and that is through
culture thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time